notre biosphère est sacrifiée pour
que les riches de pays comme le mien
puissent vivre dans le luxe ce sont les souffrances
du plus grand nombre qui paient le luxe
de quelques-uns
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de gens disent que la Suède n'est qu'un
petit pays et il  peu importe ce que
nous faisons, mais j'ai appris qu'on n'est
jamais trop petit pour faire une différence et
si quelques enfants peuvent faire la une des journaux du
monde entier simplement en n'allant pas à
l'école, alors imaginez ce que nous pourrions faire tous
ensemble si nous  Je le voulais vraiment, mais pour ce
faire, nous devons parler clairement, peu
importe à quel point cela peut être inconfortable, vous ne
parlez que de la croissance économique verte éternelle
parce que vous avez trop peur d'
être impopulaire, vous ne parlez que d'
aller de l'avant avec les mêmes mauvaises idées
qui nous ont eu  dans ce gâchis, même lorsque la
seule chose sensée à faire est de tirer le
frein d'urgence, vous n'êtes pas
assez mature pour le dire comme si c'était même ce
fardeau que vous nous laissez, les enfants, mais je
me fiche d'être populaire, je me soucie
de la justice climatique et  la
planète vivante notre civilisation est
sacrifiée pour permettre à un très
petit nombre de personnes de continuer à
gagner d'énormes sommes d'argent notre
biosphère est sacrifiée pour que les
riches de pays comme le mien puissent
vivre dans le luxe ce sont les souffrances de
beaucoup qui  payer le luxe de
quelques-uns l'an 2000 et 78 je
fêterai mon 75e anniversaire si j'ai des
enfants peut-être qu'ils passeront cette journée
avec moi peut-être qu'ils me poseront des questions sur vous
peut-être qu'ils demanderont pourquoi vous n'avez
rien fait là-bas  il était encore temps d'
agir vous dites que vous aimez vos enfants par-dessus
tout et pourtant vous volez leur
avenir sous leurs yeux jusqu'à ce que
vous commenciez à vous concentrer sur ce qui doit être
ignoré plutôt que sur ce qui est politiquement
possible il n'y a aucun espoir que nous ne puissions pas
résoudre une crise sans la traiter comme une
crise nous devons garder les combustibles fossiles
dans le sol et nous devons nous concentrer sur
l'équité et les solutions au sein de ce
système sont si impossibles à trouver que
nous devrions peut-être changer le système lui-même
nous ne sommes pas venus ici  aux grands
dirigeants mondiaux, vous nous avez ignorés dans
le passé et vous nous ignorerez à nouveau nous
n'avons plus d'excuses et nous
manquons de temps nous sommes venus ici pour
vous faire savoir que le changement arrive
que vous le vouliez ou non  le vrai
pouvoir appartient au peuple merci
[Musique]